ja meint gross ich sie ganz herzlich zum
pressing heute im robert-koch-institut
am 6 märz
ich begrüßte die anwesenden hier im saal
aber natürlich auch diejenigen die uns
über internet oder fernsehen zu schauen
wie auch schon gestern ist heute der
experte professor lothar wieler der
präsident des robert koch instituts wie
üblich wird der wähler kurz die
situation und die lage erläutern und
danach steht er für fragen zur verfügung
und auch wie üblich
danach gibt es noch die möglichkeit für
ein sammel statement ein kurzes sammle
statement im foyer und montag
schon die ankündigung wie gewohnt wieder
um 10 uhr jeden tag zusammen alle
anwesenden und auch natürlich alle die
uns auf twitter zu schauen
guten morgen zusammen zunächst möchte
ich ihnen wieder die lage schildern wie
sie sich zur zeit auf dieser welt
darstellt wie erwartet nehmen die zahlen
zu und zwar eigentlich in allen
bereichen die wir immer betrachten wir
haben heute morgen stand 7 uhr 98.000
120 fälle er weltweit das heißt wir
haben eine zunahme von 2700 sieben
fällen gegenüber gestrigen tag und
insgesamt sind 3388 menschen an der
korona virus infektion verstorben
wie immer möchte ich gern china
betrachten als ausgangsort dieser
infektion dieser epidemie und dann auf
europa schauen um dann mich auf
deutschland zu konzentrieren
der grund ist einfach der wir alle
müssen verstehen dass wir dieses virus
nicht aufhalten können dass es sich
ausbreitet sondern dass das virus eben
verlangsamt werden muss wir müssen alles
daran setzen dass wir den verbreitung
des virus verlangsamen das ist die
strategie die wir von anfang an fahren
und die wir immer weiter fahren werden
und darum ist es natürlich auch wichtig
in unsere nachbarländer zu schauen und
die welt zu schauen und wir sind
natürlich selber inzwischen in
deutschland haben wir das virus ist
breitet sich in deutschland aus und wir
exportieren eben auch fälle ins ausland
es ist also ein geschehen wo man sich
solidarisch zeigen muss und wir alle
müssen daran arbeiten dass die
geschwindigkeit der ausbreitung
verlangsamt wird
in china sind natürlich immer noch die
höchsten zahlen was sich aber im laufe
der zeit mit sehr hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit ändern wird
in china haben wir bislang 80 1667 fälle
das ist gegenüber gestern auch eine
zunahme von 147 fällen also der ausbruch
ist natürlich auch in china nicht zu
ende sondern er wird natürlich auch dort
weitergehen aber die frage ist wie
schnell es sein wird in china sind
47.000 158 menschen genesen
an dieser kannte das heißt sie haben die
krankheit überstanden sind gesund und
haben eine immunität aufgebaut in der
provinz hubei das ist nach wie vor das
größte geschehen haben wir heute 67 1592
fälle und dort sind 41 1966 genesen von
der krankheit haben sich erholt und wir
haben dort insgesamt 2900 31 todesfälle
auch da sind seit gestern 29
hinzugekommen wenn wir jetzt weiter
schauen auf die welt also die ganze
restliche welt außerhalb von chinas
betrachten dann haben wir heute 80
länder inzwischen wo das corona virus
offiziell gemeldet wurde das heißt wo
fälle offiziell gemeldet wurden und hier
sehen wir natürlich eine sehr sehr
starke zunahme wenn wir die verhältnisse
der zahlen anschauen
heute sind es 17 1453 fälle und gestern
um die zeit waren es 2500 60 fälle
weniger
also sie sehen dass dieses geschehen
sehr dynamisch ist und sich dieses virus
ausbreitet international unter diesen
fällen finden wir 3 154 todesfälle
dieses virus ist eben leider gottes in
der lage menschen zu töten es werden
menschen an dieser krankheit sterben und
das sind viele schwere verlauf fälle
lungenentzündungen in erster linie und
im internationalen kontext sehen wir
bislang 526 schwerer verlauf fälle sind
nach den reinen zahlen momentan etwa
drei prozent der zahlen die außerhalb
von chinas gemeldet wurden südkorea 6
1284 fälle iran 3513 fälle
das ist in den jeweiligen ländern auch
starke zunahmen von 30 oder 20 prozent
gegenüber gestern
jetzt schauen wir in die etwas nähere
umgebung von unserem land wäre region
euro die um fast 40 länder sehr viel in
osteuropa befindet sich in dieser region
hier gab es auch eine sehr starke
zunahme heute 5674 fälle das sind
gegenüber gestern 1320 mehr
das ist also eine ähnliche starke
zunahme wie gestern im bereich von rund
20 prozent in der region euro sind
bislang 161 todesfälle gemeldet worden
das ist eine fall sterberate von 2,84
prozent und hier finden wir 389 schwere
krankheitsverläufe in der whu region
euro sind das dann rund 6,8 prozent
schwere fälle das sind alles immer
dynamische zahlen die sich jeden tag
ändern aber die sollen ihnen und mir uns
immer klar vor augen führen dass dieses
virus zu todesfällen führen kann und
dass es eben viele schwere verlauf fälle
geben kann und auch geben wird in
italien und noch näher zu kommen sind es
3800 58 fälle
das sind 68 prozent von denen fällen die
wir zurzeit in der whu region euro haben
und in deutschland haben wir auch
inzwischen eine reihe von fällen nämlich
534 also das hat auch wieder zugenommen
und das wird natürlich weiter zunehmen
ich möchte noch mal sehr deutlich sagen
das ist wirklich so ist dass dieses
virus sich ausbreitet und eben nicht vor
ländergrenzen halt macht und dass
niemand etwas irgendwohin exportiert
oder importiert wir alle müssen dazu
beitragen diesen export und import zu
stark womöglich
zu verringern wird es lohnt sich hier
nicht auf irgendwelche länder zu schauen
sondern wir alle stehen in der pflicht
das ist dazu beizutragen dass sich das
verlangsamte nennen das die eindämmung
strategie die wenn dafür vorfahren wir
müssen versuchen die verbreitung des
virus zu verlangen jetzt komme ich auf
deutschland mal speziell wir haben also
in deutschland heute 5 134 fälle gestern
wollen das 349 es zeigt ihnen dass die
zahlen zu nehmen das ist also eine eine
kontinuierliche zunahme
das wird auch selbstverständlich in den
nächsten tagen und wochen so weitergehen
wann die der höhepunkt erreicht ist das
können wir nicht sagen wir wollen ihn so
lange wie möglich herauszögern
in deutschland sind mit dem heutigen
zeitpunkt 7 uhr heute morgen 126 in
landkreisen sind patienten benannt
worden in 15 bundesländern und nach wie
vor stellt das geschehen in heinsberg
das intensivste ausbruchsgeschehen da
dort haben wir uns inzwischen 281 fälle
heute morgen 8 uhr
und das ist eine differenz gegenüber
gestern von 100 fällen die anderen
länder in denen wir viele fälle sehen
sind baden württemberg da sind es 91
bayern da sind es 79 fälle
und dann gibt es noch andere länder in
denen es einzelfälle gibt oder
zweistellige zahlen
das sagt einfach nur dass sich
ausbreitet und ich sage mal gerade die
städte und landkreise wo wir die
höchsten zahlen aktuell haben und das
ist ein dynamisches geschehen was ich
jeden tag ändert aachen 33 landkreis
freising 17 stadt köln 15 stadt münchen
heilbronn 11 zollernalbkreis 11 freiburg
zee esslingen 10
die fälle wenn wir uns jetzt die
alterstruktur anschauen so wie wir sie
kennen es sind menschen die zwischen
zwei und 91 jahre alt der medialen welt
liegt seit 40 jahren und 55 prozent von
denen und bekannten sind
und 45 prozent deutlich etwas was immer
wichtig ist für die risikoeinschätzung
die ich ihnen gleich auch noch mal
erklären möchte für das verständnis die
risikoabschätzung für unser land
die beträgt er immer die abschätzung des
gesamten landes aber es ist natürlich
klar dass in einzelnen landkreisen das
unterschiedlich ist in heinsberg ist
natürlich eine andere situation als zum
beispiel einem landkreis in baden
württemberg oder so und in heinsberg
wenn wir anschauen wie viel der fälle in
deutschland inzwischen mit dem
geschehenen heinsberg zusammenhängen
dann sind das rund 237 fälle
das ist also viel das heißt also wir
können viele epidemiologische
zusammenhängen mit dem land kreis
heinsberg erkennen nachvollziehen
diana kam aus bayern 36 bahn wird mit 13
das sind die zahlen und nochmal jetzt im
vergleich die die kontakte von außerhalb
also von von anderen ländern die mit
denen wir den fällen in deutschland
zusammenbringen können in italien sind
das 104 in dem rahmen 15
in china zwar also die unterscheidung
zwischen inland und ausland und schauen
versuchen irgendetwas aus dem land zu
halten oder so die sind nicht hilfreich
sondern wir müssen schauen dass wir jede
quelle jede infektionsquelle die wie in
unserem land beherrschen können schnell
erkennen und den gesundheitsämtern die
chance geben diese menschen schnell zu
diagnostizieren und für quarantäne zu
sorgen wo das möglich ist und das muss
weiter so bleiben
um die ausbreitung des virus so lang wie
möglich zu verlangsamen und darum noch
mal ganz kurz gesagt ich fordere alle
auf sich das seit anfang an tue
krankenhäuser müssen sich auf
notsituationen vorbereiten die landräte
die bürgermeister müssen sich auf
notsituationen vorbereiten die
ambulanten ärzte die pandemiepläne
müssen aktiviert werden und wir müssen
alles dafür tun dass wir eine krise
meistern die auf uns zukommt und dafür
sind alle umdenken in einen krisenmodus
denken und sich überlegen wie die
patientenströme steuern wie
krankenhäuser elektiven operationen zum
beispiel absagen und so weiter und so
fort das sind alle die maßnahmen die
bekannt sind aber es mir wichtig zu
sagen dass das man auch darüber
nachdenkt und und aktuell je nach der
risikoeinschätzung die wir über die
informationen zu den einzelnen
infektionen traten und und zahlen in den
einzelnen landkreisen und und den
einzelnen gebieten in deutschland geben
dass dort entsprechend aktivitäten
starten um sich mit dem heraufkommen
dieser krise zu beschäftigen dankeschön
also wir haben gestern abend war es
nicht unglaublich gegen 21 uhr südtirol
zu einem risikogebiet erklärt der grund
dafür dass sind werden wir bestimmte
kriterien warum wir bestimmte gebiete zu
risikogebieten erklären
die kriterien sind zum einen natürlich
die anzahl der infektionen aber vor
allen dingen auch die dynamik der anzahl
also die die dynamik wie stark die
infektion zeigen steigenden in
bestimmten region umfasst ein wichtiges
kriterium ist für ein risikogebiet ist
eben auch wie viele infektionen sind aus
dem risikogebiet in andere länder
getragen worden
und das hat uns gestern dazu bewogen
südtirol zu einem risikogebiet zu
erklären
danke mikrofon
so posierte würde mich interessieren
warum südtirol ein risikogebiet das ist
heinsberg auch ein risikogebiet oder ist
diese unterscheidung da wenn du dich
noch eine frage zur fall sterberate sie
haben jetzt von 2,8
also wie gesagt es hängt ja immer von
der region ab die sie anschauen von und
aktuellen zahlen sind sehr dynamischen
zahlen also in china ist die fall
sterberate momentan 3,8 prozent und
international das heißt also im ganzen
rest der welt liegt zurzeit bei 1,9
prozent
okay aber es immer gerechnet ab alle
bekannten fällen ja das ist ja wichtig
also nochmal wir reden hier von der fall
sterberate die die idee ergibt sich
einfach aus den zahlen die wir die wir
offiziell gemeldet bekommen aber auch
noch mal zur erklärung das kann ja auch
gern noch mal erklären wir bekommen
natürlich ganz viele fälle auch gar
nicht gemeldet das heißt also wir gehen
davon aus dass es eine hohe dunkelziffer
gibt von waren fällen und dadurch gehen
wir davon aus dass die fall sterberaten
die echten die tatsächlichen geringer
sind weil wir davon ausgehen
wir wissen ja sicher dass mehr als 80
prozent der menschen infiziert werden
wirklich nur leichte symptome haben
diese zahlen bestätigen sich immer mehr
und viele die sind auch so wenig
erkrankt dass sie auch gar nicht zum
arzt gehen das sind leichte infekte
das heißt die werden alle nicht erfasst
also die zahlen die ich ihn nenne sind
einfach nur die die zahlen die offiziell
gemeldet sind und dann würde mich
interessieren es gibt ja jetzt berichte
von vielen ärzten die sagen sie testen
dich weil sie einfach das material nicht
haben ist es also selbst wenn es wenn
man selber vermutet dass man den virus
in sich trägt würden sie im moment
empfehlen dann eben nicht zum arzt zu
gehen und einfach zu hause zu bleiben
oder würden sie empfehlen wenn man in
einem risikogebiet zb war auf jeden fall
zum arzt zu gehen um eben die statistik
vollständig
das ist das ist eine gute frage noch mal
wieder auch oft gefragt werden und
natürlich die ärzte werden oft gefragt
und ich möchte dass meine ganz
prinzipiell kommentieren warum zeichnen
wie risikogebiete aus dass ganz einfach
sie möchten einen arzt
informationen an die hand geben nach
denen er patienten einordnen kann ja
wenn zum beispiel ein patient symptome
hat sagen wir grippeähnliche symptome
fieber husten schnupfen
wenn dieser patient aus einem
risikogebiet kommt dann ist natürlich
die chance dass er vielleicht mit diesem
virus infiziert war größer als wenn es
ein patient werde eben nicht aus einem
risikogebiet kommt das heißt es gibt
einfach dem arzt mehr kriterien um zu
einer testung zu kommen oder nicht da
dafür gibt es die risikogebiete das ist
der das ist der entscheidende punkt wir
wollen dem arzt quasi handwerkszeug
geben damit er sich genau überlegen kann
ob er jemand testet oder nicht und das
gilt natürlich jetzt der zweite punkt
ist aber der alleine aus einem risiko b
zu kommen sagt natürlich gar nichts aus
wenn man zum weil ich nehme ich gebe
ihnen ein beispiel einer unserer
mitarbeiter war bei der whu mission
dabei vor einer woche in wochen oder in
china er war unter anderem aber auch
info hahn und ingo hahn ist ja dass nach
wie vor noch dass das quasi dass das
zentrum dieses ausbruches wir haben da
immer weniger neue fälle aber dieses
diese ganze stadt ist immer noch unter
quarantäne gesetzt
das ist also ein risikogebiet aber
dieser mitarbeiter ist in diesem risiko
gut gewesen aber ist aber überhaupt
niemals mit einem infizierten patienten
in kontakt gekommen also mit einem
klinisch manifesten patienten
das heißt der hat eine so genannte
kategorie 2 risiko es gibt bestimmte
kategorien die haben wir den den ärzten
die wissen dass alle menschen können
also unsere website angucken das
verstehen also nur weil ich in einem
risikogebiet bin heißt es noch lange
nicht dass ich ein kategorie 1
risikopatienten und angesteckt sein muss
wenn ich ein risiko zwei patienten wie
dieser mitarbeiter von uns dann heißt
das dass ich ganz normal zur arbeit
gehen kann ganz normal mein tagesablauf
mache dass ich mich aber selber einfach
mal monitoren also selber vielleicht
morgens und abends fiebermesser schaue
ob ich krank werde wenn ich dann krank
werden sollte dann würde ich einen arzt
anrufen sagen pass auf ich war in diesem
gebiet
zwei wochen es geht immer um die
inkubationszeit ich war in diesem gebiet
ich möchte gerne auf corona virus
getestet werden man kann nicht zu ihnen
kommen um mich testen zu lassen und dann
wenn ein arzt gut organisiert ist und
das erwarten wir natürlich zunehmend
dass die arztpraxen eben auch ihre
patientenströme anders steuern
dann sagen die ok sag mal ein beispiel
wir machen diese patienten die mit
fieber kommen oder die krank sind die
wir von denen wir denken die haben so
die symptome
die kommen jetzt immer nur ab 4 uhr
abends oder so nachmittags und die
anderer patienten machen anderen zeiten
da müssen natürlich die patienten das
auch verstehen und müssen dann anrufen
es geht darum dass wir alle unser
verhalten ein wenig an eine krise
anpassen das wichtig wir können alles
dafür tun das heißt also wenn diese zwei
faktoren mann ist krank und man war in
einem risikogebiet innerhalb der letzten
zwei wochen weil es um eine
inkubationszeit geht für sie erstellt
dann würde man sich auf auf dann hat man
eine indikation mit pcr auf das corona
virus getestet zu werden
ansonsten aber nicht ja oder wenn man
natürlich aus dem land kommt wo sehr
viele fälle sind das dass diese
informationen geben wir auch also man
muss auf jeden fall basiert an den
informationen die man kennt hat man ein
höheres risiko vielleicht angesteckt
worden seien oder nicht
wenn jemand hier in deutschland lebt und
hat mit niemandem kontakt ist nicht
krank macht es gar keinen sinn dass er
irgendwo hingeht zum testen sondern der
führt nur dazu dass er die kapazitäten
die die wirklich kranken menschen
brauchen wegnimmt
er nimmt dem krankenhaus eine kapazität
wie vor vielleicht wirklich
möglicherweise infizierten patienten
testen würde darum muss man sich das
wirklich überlegen man muss ganz in ruhe
sich unsere website angucken muss ich
ganz in ruhe überlegen hatte ich eine
risiko mich anzustecken oder nicht und
dann ruft man den arzt dann ruft die 11
6 11 7 oder hass der 11 7 11 6
entschuldigen sie aber auf inhalte die
die nummer von der kbv es wirklich
wichtig wenn man dann zentral informiert
wird und dann weiter geschaltet wird
also informationen einholen sich
informieren ist wirklich wichtig
wirklich wichtig und dann geht man erst
zu einem arzt ja
das war die frage glaube ich eine
heinsberg ist ein gebiet auf dem auf
jeden fall ein gebiet wo vermehrt fälle
sind und natürlich wenn man in heinsberg
gewesen wäre und kontakt gehabt hätte zu
menschen die krank waren dann sollte man
und man selber kriegt symptome dann ist
man jemand den hörer wahrscheinlichkeit
hat angesteckt zu sein als in anderen
regionen absolut maxiq abbas von der
tagesschau herr professor wieder ich
habe zwei fragen das eine sie haben
gesagt die das system sollte sich auf
eine krise vorbereiten einstellen aber
es gibt ja bereits die klage über
überlastung von der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung von anderen wie also kann
man sich sollte man sich aus ihrer sicht
darauf vorbereiten dieser krise
gewachsen zu sein ist die erste frage ob
die zweite haben sie schon auf
beantwortet bitte noch einmal weil sie
heute mehrfach auf die wichtigkeit des
verlangsamen hingewiesen haben wo warum
das so wichtig ist und bis wohin sie
gerne verlangsamen
ich muss sagen ich hab jetzt die erste
frage wieder vergessen können sie
nochmal kurz sagen die krise im system
insgesamt wie man sich da wappnen kann
der klage dass man überlastet ist die
ist ja schon da ja also der der ganz
normale betrieb wie wir in unserem land
immer zum arzt gehen wann immer wir
denken wir müssen zum arzt gehen und
denken dass wir jederzeit dort
ansprechpartner finden diese diese
denkweise muss sich ein wenig ändern ja
sondern man sollte wirklich nur noch zum
arzt gehen wenn es wirklich notwendig
ist wie sollten das gesundheitssystem
nicht überlasten mitpatienten dass das
eine dass wir selber darüber nachdenken
ob es wirklich jetzt zwingend notwendig
ist dass wir zum arzt gehen das zweite
ist natürlich das gesundheitssystem
selber sie sagen dass das ist zurzeit
unter anderem deshalb überlastet weil
auch viel zu viele menschen zum arzt
gehen die eigentlich gar keinen grund
haben die sorge haben und das kann ich
verstehen dass sie mit in fred mit dem
corona virus infiziert werden und die
dann aber unnötigerweise in praxen gehen
und dann zugänge
haben wir es einfach verstopfen so
zusagen von seiten des gesundheitssystem
heißt es aber dass man eben ist das
beispiel immer wieder es gibt bestimmte
eingriffe in den hospitälern
die sind zeitlich unabhängig wie kann
man vielleicht auch in zwei monaten
machen die sollte man natürlich dann ab
sagen ja das heißt also für patienten
die wirklich kommen und schwer erkrankt
sind die bei uns in deutschland ja auch
kommen werden
und dann sollte man sich auf die
konzentrieren man sollte sich darauf
konzentrieren dass man zum beispiel
intensivbetten eben frei hält wenn das
möglich ist und diese dinge das sind
also ganz normale logistische vorgänge
die auch jeder arzt in seiner praxis vor
denkt und auch die jedes krankenhaus vor
denkt also der routinebetrieb schwenkt
um in ein krisen betrieb wo man einfach
bestimmte dinge priorisieren muss und
bestimmte lange operation nehmen wir
jetzt mal ich selber da steht irgendwie
eine operation an die verschiebe ich
eben um ein halbes jahr und solche dinge
also dass das heißt also jeder muss
darüber nachdenken ob er jetzt zwingend
behandelt werden muss oder will und
jeder arzt muss darüber nachdenken was
eine priorität hat und nicht das heute
ist diese problematik der der testungen
wir haben in deutschland eine ganz ganz
ganz ganz hohe kapazität dass wir testen
können menschen auf das vorhandensein
des corona virus die sollte eben
wirklich und einen anspruch genommen
werden wenn es einen echten anlass gibt
ja da sind die zwei dinge die ich dazu
sagen kann und die zweite frage die
verlangsamung
also ich möchte das noch mal so erklären
sie haben das auch schon oft gehört und
dass das ist so wenn so eine epidemie
durch ein land geht und wir stehen ja
vor dieser epidemie
wir haben sie noch nicht aber die
dynamik spricht dafür dass für sie bald
haben werden
dann müssen sie sich vorstellen dass in
deutschland ein großteil der menschen
infiziert wird weil das ja eine epidemie
ist gegen die es keine immunität gibt in
der bevölkerung dass wir uns ist ja ein
neuartiges virus und es gibt auch keinen
impfstoff
und das heißt also wir müssen einfach
dafür sorge tragen dass nicht zu viele
patienten zum selben zeitpunkt auftreten
man will einfach den die anzahl der
fälle über einen längeren zeitraum
strecken
und wenn sie fragen wie lange wir den
strecken wollen
können wir nur sagen wir wollen ihn
strecken so lange es geht ja das wird
es gibt überlegungen dass das virus in
ein zwei jahren vielleicht durch unser
land geht
das ist möglich es kann sein dass das
virus so etwa wie eine saisonale grippe
irgendwann saisonal wird und tatsächlich
dann jedes jahr wieder neu kommen dann
sind viele der menschen gesagt über 80
prozent haben wir nur milde symptome
haben eine eine immunität und dann kann
sich das virus nicht mehr so ausbreiten
das heißt es geht einfach darum egal wie
viele menschen infiziert werden
je länger es dauert bis sie infiziert
werden desto mehr kann natürlich unser
gesundheitssystem sich um die schwer
kranken kommen
das ist der ganze punkt wir wollen so
lange es geht verlangsamt und daran
müssen alle arbeiten und alle nachdenken
wie viele fälle in deutschland hängen
damit zusammen ich weiß hier von der
berliner schulklasse sind das noch mehr
und also auch seines länder also dass
italien das gar nicht als risikogebiet
sieht sie aber schon weil wir hier
rückkehrer haben
ich kann ihnen jetzt nichts sagen wie
jeder italiener über das denkt dass das
weiß ich nicht
wir haben also nach dem jetzigen stand
waren es 36 fälle die wir momentan heute
morgen damit in zusammenhang bringen
konnten
ach so ein drittel der fälle aus italien
kommen aus südtirol sagt von glas machen
ja also das heißt das ist viel
ja das ist eine direkte überlegung die
man anstellen sollte klar er absagen
sollte gibt es dann ratschlag von ihnen
wann fängt es an eine überreaktion zu
sein
wie können sich die behörden am besten
orientieren naja ich sage es nochmal das
ganze schien das ganze was wir was wir
betrachten wir geben ja entsprechend
ratschläge wir weisen ja bestimmte
gebiete aus die ein höheres risiko dass
die infektionen verbreiten und es ist es
wird eben immer so sein dass auch
innerhalb von deutschlands gebiete
verschiedene risikogruppen haben und es
hängt davon ab wo man sich befindet ob
man eine großveranstaltung absagt oder
nicht wir geben die kriterien vor die
dazu dienen und die jeweiligen
veranstalter müssen sich überlegen ob
sie unter den aktuellen bedingungen eine
großveranstaltung durchführen oder nicht
aber die aktuellen bedingungen werden
auch über deutschland folgt teilt
unterschiedlich sein
das wird auch immer so bleiben ja es
wird immer unterschiedliche gebiete
geben mit unterschiedlichen risiken zu
fall entscheiden
dazu muss nur aktuelle lagebewertung
faszinatour im deutschlandfunk und wdr
es ist ja so weit ich weiß jetzt noch so
dass quarantäne regeln gelten für ärzte
und praxen und krankenhäuser wenn
festgestellt wurde wir hatten hier einen
patienten der wirklich positiv getestet
wurde das eigentlich dann alle die mit
ihm kontakt hatten in quarantäne sollten
jetzt gibt es erste meldungen dass die
befürchtung besteht dass man dann den
alltag in den oder denen die den service
nicht mehr aufrechterhalten kann
sehen sie das auf dauer da vielleicht
die quarantäne regeln geändert werden
sollten und in welche richtung also
schön dass sie das nochmal ansprechen
weil mich das wirklich fast schon maßlos
ärgert dass das immer noch der eindruck
entsteht dass jeder der vielleicht mit
einem patienten ein kontakt hat in
quarantäne muss das war niemals der fall
sondern das ist eine extreme
vereinfachung der empfehlung die wir
geben und alle ärzte und ihre jeder
bürger der kann ja gerne mal auf das
schema schauen was wir im internet haben
wird sehen dass es drei kategorien gibt
drei kategorien von kontakten und das
habe ich ja gerade und noch mehr zu
erklären versucht es gibt sehr
unterschiedliche intensitäten wie eng
sie mit einem patienten in kontakt waren
wie lange sie mit einem kurzen patienten
in kontakt waren und das heißt je
nachdem von der intensität wie die
chance wahr dass sie sich vielleicht
angesteckt haben oder nicht macht es sie
in quarantäne zu gehen oder nicht also
die behauptung dass wenn ein patient in
einer praxis gewesen wäre die praxis
geschlossen werden müsste ist
schlichtweg falsch
unabhängig davon möchte noch mal
folgendes sagen das sind empfehlungen
die wir geben und empfehlungen sind dazu
da dass sie möglichst eingehalten werden
aber jede empfehlung kann natürlich
unter bestimmten bedingungen wenn es
eben die verhältnismäßigkeit zeigt wenn
sie nicht mehr eingehalten werden kann
dann kann sie natürlich nicht mehr
eingehalten werden
das ist auch klar ja das heißt also man
muss ja immer die verhältnismäßigkeit im
auge haben und bei den empfehlungen
steht natürlich im vordergrund der
schutz des medizinischen fachpersonal
sonst der ärzte es ist unser aller
pflicht auch die davor zu schützen dass
ich während ihrer arbeit anstecken und
da auch noch mal eine ganz einfache
aussage lungeninfektion die gibt es
solange es menschen gibt ja das ist
überhaupt kein neues krankheitsgeschehen
wir haben ja neuartiges virus gegen das
wir noch kein medikament haben und gegen
das hier noch kein impfstoff haben auch
lungenentzündung und damit handeln ärzte
jeden tag das ist nichts
außergewöhnliches und das heißt also
dann gehen die auch nicht in quarantäne
wenn die influenza patienten ihrer ihrer
praxis haben es muss angemessen sein und
situationsbedingt passt man das an und
ich sage es nochmal zunehmend wenn wir
wenn in bestimmten regionen krisen
auftreten dann wird man natürlich immer
mehr anpassen müssen was noch machbar
ist und was verhältnismäßig ist
nochmal zum schutz des medizinischen
personals können sie doch mal was zum
bestand von schutzbekleidung sagen und
zu ausfuhr verboten
um diesen bestand zu schützen ja also
wir müssen natürlich klar vor augen
haben da ja dieses virus sich sehr weit
verbreitet und vielen teilen der welt
unterwegs ist wird es natürlich sehr
sehr viel bedarf geben für
schutzkleidung und schutzmaßnahmen
masken schutzbrillen was was immer man
sich jetzt so vorstellt das heißt also
die die maßnahme dass man exportverbot
erteilt halte ich für verhältnismäßig
wir alle müssen dafür schauen dass du so
viel wie möglich an schutzkleidung
bekommen und es wird alles dafür getan
dass so viel wie möglich erhalten wird
es gibt inzwischen in deutschland zb
auch firmen die bestimmte aus bestimmte
andere sachen herstellen normalerweise
wie zum beispiel hersteller von
matratzen oder so die aber materialien
haben die gebraucht werden um zum
beispiel mund nasenschutz herzustellen
die switchen um ihre produktion
es gibt also sehr sehr viel wo auch
wirklich mit mit klarem kopf mit klarem
verstand neue strategien entwickelt
werden um dafür zu sorgen dass wir so
viel wie möglich
schutzmasken und und atemmasken in
unserem land haben das ist klar das wird
der wird alles versucht um den bestand
zu gut wie möglich zu sichern
und natürlich werden auch es wird alles
daran angepasst dass immer noch der
gesundheitsschutz oben steht aber es
wird wir werden niemals unter eine
bestimmte grenze bei unseren
empfehlungen runtergehen
aber wenn irgendwann in einer praxis
bestimmte masse nicht mehr da sind dann
muss man sich auch anders behelfen das
ist klar ja also ich sage es nochmal wir
müssen uns auf eine krise vorbereiten wo
man vielleicht nicht immer alles dazu
tun können wie man es routinemäßig immer
getan hat das ist so in einer krise da
brauchen wir solidarität
da brauchen wir einen klugen kopf 1 1
ja bei bayer heißem herzen aber einen
klugen kopf überlegen was man tut und
das können jetzt jetzt zu wissen wie man
es gibt wenn sie mal in einer
notaufnahme gearbeitet haben dann wissen
sie dass dort immer entschieden werden
muss was man macht das dass das gehört
zu dem alltag dazu und wir müssen
einfach immer darüber nachdenken was
können wir tun um die ausbeutung dieses
virus wirklich einzuschränken
die kolleginnen und ich wollte sie
bitten vielleicht noch mal in einfachen
worten zu erklären wie man sich jetzt
verhalten soll wenn man in den letzten
zwei wochen in südtirol im urlaub fahren
und da ganz normal
naja das ist also ich sags noch mal als
sie die menschen die dort gewesen sind
das waren ja vorwiegend skiurlauber wir
sollten sie sich selber beobachten wie
sie sollten schauen wenn sie krank
werden also wenn sie wirklich
symptomatisch werden also zur grippe
ähnliche grippeähnliche symptome haben
dann sollten sie wenn möglich zu hause
bleiben das ist das eine
damit sie möglichst wenig andere
anstecken sie sollten einen arzt anrufen
bzw diese nummer von der kbv anrufen und
sollen sie informieren und dann sollten
sie mit einem arzt sprechen und dann
sollten sie mit dem arzt einen termin
vereinbaren
der arzt wird in einer am telefon sagen
ob sie sich testen lassen sollen oder
nicht
und wenn das gegeben ist dann werden sie
getestet und wird man schauen was das
ergebnis ist und dann werden sie in
ärztliche behandlung wenn sie positiv
sind werden sie in ärztliche behandlung
gehen und je nachdem wie stark der
effekt ist wissen der wie bei über 80
prozent der menschen ein klarer leichter
effekt ist dann können sie das auch zu
hause auskurieren und wenn es eine
schwere verlaufsform ist dann werden sie
vom arzt behandelt ambulant und wenn es
ein ganz schwerer verlauf ist dann
werden sie ins krankenhaus eingewiesen
dort fanden das heißt also sich selber
beobachten und versuchen keine anderen
menschen anzustecken
iris heufert vom nachrichtensender welt
herr professor doktor wieder kurz eine
nachfrage zu den großveranstaltungen
morgen findet in mönchengladbach im
bundesliga spiel statt
vor 50.000 menschen 37 kilometer vom
kreis heinsberg entfernt wie bewerten
sie diese veranstaltung dass die
stattfindet ist das verantwortungsvoll
und dann zum virus eine frage
unterschiedlich aggressive virusstämme
da wird auch sehr viel darüber
diskutiert inwieweit haben sie da schon
erkenntnisse bekommen welche es gibt in
deutschland und welche unterschiedlichen
gefahren von denen ausgehen
letzte fragen im kontext wann rechnen
sie mit therapeutischer also
medikamenten zur behandlung die schnell
helfen können und darüber hinaus wann
kann man mit einem impfstoff rechnen
weltweit in einem jahr in einer type
oder später
danke ja zur ersten frage wie ich ja
dabei ist ich bin fan vom fc köln
aber ich kann dazu nur sagen das sind
wirklich die entscheidung der lokalen
behörden um das um das ganz deutlich zu
sagen das müssen die lokalen behörden
einschätzen sie haben unsere kriterien
die sind bekannt und das müssen die
lokalen behörden einschätzen ob sie
diese veranstaltung durchführen oder
nicht der zweite punkt sprachen sie an
mit medikamenten therapeutika und den
viren also die frage zu den viren kann
ich sehr gut beantworten das tolle in
dieser zeit wirklich ich sage das ganz
bewusst wirklich toll ist wie rasch
aufgrund technologischer fortschritte so
institute wie auch unser eigenes
institut inzwischen das erbgut von
diesen wären entschlüsseln können das
hilft uns unglaublich weil wir darüber
nicht nur die verbreitung des virus sehr
sehr schön nachvollziehen können sondern
wir können von dem erbgut von den genen
informationen auch sehr sehr gut
abschätzen was sich welche biologie sich
hinter diesem virus verbirgt und da
können wir zurzeit sagen das ist ja
jetzt also seit dem siebten januar
bekannt das ist eine ganz ganz kurze
zeit und wir haben schon mehrere hundert
genomsequenz analysiert und die werden
auf öffentlichen repositorien werden
diese das erbgut dargestellt dann kann
man das analysieren wir sehen dass sich
doch mutationen zeigen das ist ganz
normal also kleine veränderungen aber es
gibt noch keinerlei hinweis dass diese
kleinen veränderungen
irgendwas mit der biologie des virus
machen dass das virus in irgendeiner
weise sagen wir mal mehr schwere
krankheitsfälle hervor ruft oder nicht
es ist sogar von dem verständnis also
von dem infektions biologischen
evolutionären verständnis her ist es
sogar eher das gegenteil zu erwarten
dieses virus wird sich von von seiner
biologie her eher an den menschen
anpassen und dann zu milden verläufen
führen das ist eigentlich die hypothese
die viele wissenschaftler haben die sich
mit solchen dingen befassen
ich habe mich ja auch ich befasse mich
auch sehr viel mit der evolution von
krankheitserregern das ist auch meine
einschätzung die falsche therapeutika
wir haben wir wir wissen dass in china
sehr viele klinische studien
durchgeführt werden und auch da möchte
ich noch einmal betonen dass die
wirklich eine hohe qualität haben und
dass da viele substanzen ausprobiert
werden
es zeichnet sich substanzen ab die von
denen ich hoffe dass sie in wenigen
wochen dann auch eingesetzt werden es
werden ja war als jetzt so genannte
experimentelle therapeutischer
eingesetzt
aber wir wissen noch nicht genau wie gut
sie wirken das sind experimentelle
studien das ist auch richtig so
wenn man kein medikament hat dann muss
man natürlich auch experimentell was
machen aber ich gehe davon aus dass
wirklich in wenigen wochen medikamente
bekannt sind die tatsächlich den kranken
helfen aber ich möchte auch hier noch
mal sagen das ist natürlich dann das
gilt natürlich dann auch für alle
menschen nicht nur die in deutschland
leben sondern es gibt ja in anderen
ländern ebenfalls menschen die schwere
infektionskrankheiten haben werden und
dann muss es auch keine solidarität
geben das dann zum beispiel
pharmazeutische unternehmen produktions
produktion hochfahren sind also
mechanismen die geschehen müssen der
impfstoff die frage noch mal ganz ganz
deutlich es ist nicht damit zu rechnen
dass ein impfstoff vor 20 21
einsatzbereit ist wir lesen oft und zu
recht auch das auch total in ordnung es
ist aber von der presse dann oft nicht
in den richtigen kontext gesetzt
es gibt impfstoffkandidaten ich gehe
davon aus dass es in wenigen wochen
impfstoffkandidaten gibt die sind im
labor aufgrund der tollen technik die
wir inzwischen weltweit haben auch in
deutschland gibt es wirklich großartige
forscher die daran arbeiten und zusammen
mit fahrzeug unternehmen da gibt es
viele verbündete die sich vielleicht vor
zehn jahren noch gar nicht getroffen
hätten die jetzt einfach wirklich
ergebnisorientiert zusammenarbeiten dann
wird es eben stoffe geben aber bis sie
die in der breiten bevölkerung
vor impfen können muss eine menge getan
werden an testung und das sind klinische
testungen die erwarten wir
wir möchten nicht nur dass ein impfstoff
hilft wir wollen auch dass er keinen
schaden anrichtet wir wollen keine
impfschäden und darum muss das getestet
werden in kleinen studien dass ein ganz
normales prozedere das dauert monate
und ich kann mir vorstellen dass man ist
hier besonders beschleunigt aber es wird
trotzdem nicht vor dem jahr 20 21
impfstoffe geben die diese zulassung der
deutschen behörden und auch der
internationalen behörde nehme jetzt in
amsterdam ist nicht nur in london oder
der fdp in den usa entsprechen und sie
werden sie können davon ausgehen dass
gerade die zulassungsbehörden alle
menschen alle entscheidungsträger alles
dafür tun werden dass alle möglichen
vorgänger gerade verwaltungsvorgänge
bürokratische folge der sein müssen dass
die alle größtmöglich beschleunigt
werden das ist uns auch einer der gründe
warum heute sich die gesundheitsminister
der eu wieder treffen in paris um über
solche dinge zu sprechen
hier braucht es solidarität hier braucht
es schnelle lösungen
hier muss man einfach mal auch eine fünf
gerade sein lassen und bestimmte dinge
beschleunigen und das haben alle
verstanden das ist gut so und das wird
uns allen helfen denn jede woche die wir
gewinnen wird uns helfen nur eine
nachfrage das heißt diese meldung dass
es zwei verschiedene virusstämme oder
zwei sehr unterschiedliche virusstämme
geben gibt ein aggressiver eines weniger
aggressiv sind ministern kann diese
meldungen aus wissenschaftlicher sicht
und kann ich nicht nachvollziehen
bin jetzt niemand übersehen haben mit
fragen dann bedanken uns ganz herzlich
für ascom und oder fürs zuschauen zu
werden und im anschluss noch
die üblichen statements